pro football hall of famer love this
man's work with one of my favorite
people joe buck
pro football hall of famer troy aikman
here on the rich eisen show how are you
troy
i'm good rich how are you i'm doing fine
i will just
go and throw the floor straight open to
you what did you think of super bowl
55 and what we saw last night troy
well um you know i thought going in rich
i expected it to be
i i did not think it would be a shootout
uh i thought it would be a low scoring
game
overall uh compared to when you look at
these two teams and how explosive they
could be
and i just thought that defensively what
todd bowles was able to i actually just
got through the film
great uh and and and watched and you
know what they were able to do i
you know they they mixed things up
pretty good they were not going to give
up big plays they were able to get to
mahomes with a four-man rush and i think
flustered them a little bit i think that
you know they uh sometimes when you're
used to getting big plays down the field
and
and then when those don't happen you
tend to get a little bit frustrated as
an offense and
they just never could quite get in sync
where you look at their third downs and
their inability to convert and maintain
possession of the ball
not come away with touchdowns in the red
zone and uh
and then as many penalties as they had
too many of those
were obviously pretty costly in that
game so
uh just an overall great performance by
tampa bay and
what they were able to do towards the
end of the season and then throughout
the postseason
so i you know obviously a lot will be
made was made
is going to be made about the two
stellar left tackles for the chi
uh left and right tackles for the chiefs
being
out uh and i don't want us to basically
say well it would have been a totally
different result
uh had they had fisher and schwartz
played because that might you know
denigrate the remarkable talents that we
saw on that front seven
last night how how do you think that
played out having seen
the the film already troy uh yeah no i
it definitely
it it's a factor i mean anytime you've
got uh
when you miss an offensive lineman a
particularly edge blockers
against the pass rush like tampa bay has
it uh
it affects things and and it did but
i i thought i thought early in that game
rich if you take away
patrick mahomes let's just say in the
first half mahomes
he had some scrambles did a nice job um
but but tampa bay played a lot of
coverage and they were
they were wanting kansas city to beat
them running the football and
and elaire edward zulair he he had just
four carries in that first half and
came out in the second half had a couple
nice runs on the opening possession of
the third quarter
and then after that possession failed to
do anything
you know then it became a passing game
early in that third quarter because of
the score they were down three scores
but
you know i thought that they could have
could have maybe been a little more
balanced trying to run the football
against some of those looks that
tampa bay was showing uh it would have
helped out the offensive line
but at the end of the day if you're not
keeping the opponent from coming away
with points the way that they were able
to then
you know we see what happened the game
starts to get away from you and then you
have no choice and then that makes
things even harder troy aikman pro
football hall of famer
nfl on fox analyst here on the rich
eisen show
can you put into words what tom brady is
doing
right now no i
i don't know that i don't know that
anybody can i i'm uh
i'm a huge fan of tom's i have been for
a long long time i love the way he plays
the game
uh i i said it during the post season
when we had
we had tampa in new orleans uh with drew
brees and brady and i just think that
there's a lot to
learn watching those guys play the
position
and for tom he just knows situations
uh i i don't know
i i think it's a lost art to some degree
uh because we're in this kind of fantasy
world to where it's all about numbers
and throwing the football and everybody
points to
statistics uh to determine you know how
somebody's doing but i think that
you know brady obviously has the numbers
but
he just knows what's required in
virtually every situation
uh to give his team the best chance to
win and nobody's won
at a higher level more than him of
course and uh
it's remarkable i mean it really is and
i think that
what what bruce arian said after the nfc
championship
game i thought was really telling he
said it just took one man we needed one
man to show us how to do it
and and i think that's taken away from
the staff and certainly bruce arians but
the point was well taken that
brady came in and immediately gave that
team a belief and i think franchise
quarterbacks do that
uh patrick mahomes has done that for
kansas city you know we can go through
the list aaron rodgers with green bay
drew brees with new orleans but
you know that's what tampa bay needed
and they obviously have done a really
good job assembling that roster
i thought week one when we had them
against the
uh the saints to open up the season that
those two teams in the nfc
were the most complete teams on both
sides of the ball
and then for tampa to be able to put it
together when at one point at seven and
five
it did not look good they had really
only green bay was a good team that they
had beaten
and uh they got on a roll at the end of
the year and then they played three real
good teams in the postseason great
quarterbacks hall of fame quarterback
and uh we're really dominant so it was
uh it was a fun
fun year for us for fox for me to follow
tampa from week one all the way through
to the end of the season and uh
watch them win it all so i mean if you
could bottle something though
and say that you know to a kid coming
out of college here drink this because
this is what tom brady
uh has right like if you could somehow
some way uh boil that
conversation you know boil that point
that you just made about he knows
how to handle everything in the moment
perfectly for for his teammates and and
obviously he's not infallible
we have seen him beaten in regular and
post seasons before but it just seems
that
you know we you know we i i know about
the fire that burns within
and and the competitor that it does
require to have a bust in the same room
that you have one in in canton troy but
what it can you can you break it down
for me in any of the exo's conversations
you've had with tom
uh or just watching the film that you
saw last night something that can
actually
uh come up with uh a way to show
brady's greatness in the moment
well i think a great example of it rich
is in the nfc championship game that we
had
against the packers they had a
five-point lead they're right on the
verge
they're right within field goal range i
mean they couldn't afford to take a sack
and and i commented on it before the
snap of the ball that
you know brady cannot take a sack he
knows that better than anybody
right because i know how i just know how
his mind works and
he's not going to make a mistake like
that in that area knowing how
important those three points were well
the ball snapped
and immediately has a free rusher in his
face and he just
throw he doesn't try to get away from
him he doesn't try to you know
he just immediately throws it at the
receiver speak and it
to a lot of people it looked odd you
know like wow you know almost as though
there was a penalty or a false start on
the play the ball came out that fast
and it was just a great example of him
just not going to risk taking a sack and
taking his team out of field goal range
knowing how important those three points
were and
and it's little things like that within
the game
i i've said many times that
when when you start a game as a
quarterback when you're playing
in a in a 0-0 game or
if in the fourth quarter you're playing
with a with a seven point lead or a ten
point lead or a five point that
all those things you play the game
differently
you don't you don't take the same risks
you understand how your defense is
playing
and all of that has to as a quarterback
all of that has to be factored in as as
to what you then have to do
as the quarterback of the team to try to
move the football or to try to come away
with points or
just simply not lose it and i just feel
that
there's there's a lot of there's a
there's
that art i don't know i don't know how
much of that is truly
coached um whereas when you're talking
about guys
you know that are successful on a
consistent basis
and since we're talking about tom brady
you know those guys that he understands
it he understands those little nuances
and gives his team the best chance to
win
in in every given situation we saw that
from peyton manning throughout his
career
uh it's uh as a as a former player
uh it's something that i've always
admired about tom brady and the way that
he plays the game and
and uh and i love watching it on display
and
i just a really smart heavy player a guy
who
doesn't move particularly well never has
uh but yet he's been so efficient and
being able to get the most out of
of of his ability and and be uh in
you know i said it after he won his
fifth super bowl the the best that's
ever done it
and it's hard to imagine that anybody's
ever going to be able to do it better
10 super bowls he's been in troy i mean
that's insane i mean
crazy you know better than in 21 years i
mean
it's crazy the numbers are just absurd
and
and and and it did seem like mahomes
being off to the start that he was on
it he won last night um would have been
on pace and obviously they would have
just been a quarter of the way
but um you know or a fifth of the way
just 20
of the way towards what brady has been
able to do so
troykman here on the rich eisen show
what do you what do you say about
the chief's next maneuvers here and what
they learned from last night you just
chalk it up to
just wasn't their night andy reed you
know his his team just looked way off
you can't i mean your dad too
can only wonder what was going through
andy reid's mind with his own son
and what was going on with his own son
and the accident that took place that
that uh affected others in in a
significant way
a frightening way i mean you just i
don't know how you put it all together
is that just a bad
night or or do you think that this is
something that uh brett veach is gonna
be able to put his finger on and say
this won't happen again x y and z
yeah i think there's uh i mean first of
all it's hard to get to the super bowl
and uh they had a great year i mean they
did a lot of really great things
last night of course was not their best
night and i
i don't think one game defines a season
or one game defines a team
uh the challenge for them as it is for a
few other teams is can they come back
and kind of you know put this game
behind them
and and then go back and do it all over
again next year it's
it sounds like you know for i'm sure you
feel the same way you say oh yeah
they're going to be
you know really good again and i would
expect them to be but there are no
guarantees and
and and it no matter how good of a
season you're having no matter how good
you are
talent wise there's always these bumps
in the road during the course of the
year and how well you navigate that
determines
whether or not you ultimately have a
successful season
so you know time will tell but i do
think kansas city is going to be
knocking on the door
each and every year while patrick
mahomes is their quarterback
but i think you bring up a good point as
far as the situation that andy reid and
and
and his son find themselves in
and it's hard to try to determine just
how big of a factor
that was in the game i i would have to
believe that it
impacted at some level i mean i would
think that it
it certainly would have affected andy
reid it would only be natural
uh for anyone who has children to be in
that position you can understand and
then to try to get ready for
you know what is the biggest game of the
season
uh i i i i feel bad for all parties
involved
um and hate that it's happened to such a
a really good person in andy reid but uh
yeah my heart goes out to everybody and
hopefully uh
that all works out but yeah it's hard to
determine exactly what the impact of all
that might have been on the chiefs troy
aikman few minutes left here
with troy on the rich eisen show um you
obviously
uh know what the number 88 means to
michael i do too
uh we hear about the 88 club all the
time hear about it all the time the
original
the original has finally gotten the call
from the hall of fame i i wonder what
you think of uh
what you thought of the the class writ
large but obviously
the fact that uh drew pearson got the
call after all this time
troy yeah i was so happy for drew i just
know
i just know how important it was to him
how let down
he has been in recent years especially
last year when he thought that he would
be going in and
and had a party and was unable to to get
voted in
and and uh you know as emotional as he
was i think
that anyone who questioned how
important it was to him i think we all
got to see you know how much it
meant and so i'm really happy for him
rich and the other one that i'm really
happy for is
is john lynch having played against him
and knowing
you know his impact on the game and and
really was somewhat surprised that he
hadn't gotten in the last couple of
years when he's been eligible but
uh i thought that was very deserving as
well all of them um
are very very deserving and really happy
for
you know i think that you think that
you had you had a great career and and
when you don't get in
uh you know i've heard a lot of these
guys talk about it you think well that's
okay i mean
still had a great career and would have
been nice but it's not the end of the
world but then once they do get voted in
uh you can see just how special it is
and how how much it means to all of
these guys so
uh it was a great time i love what david
baker is doing as far as going and
knocking on these guys doors and the way
that they've let them know especially
this year with the pandemic
i just think that david baker's doing a
lot of wonderful things and
and hopefully uh the best part of all
this is the ceremony and hopefully we
get a chance to have it this year it's
gonna be
it's gonna be a lot of people going in
this thing maybe a week-long
uh ceremony to get everybody into the
hall of fame that's uh that's been voted
in but yeah really happy for everybody
and uh and for drew pearson and
and uh for the as long as he's been
waiting to get in yeah we had jimmy
johnson on last week troy said he's
gonna give the shortest hall of fame
speech ever is what he said
that's what he was saying he's on record
and i said i will take him up on that
because there's an absurd number of
speeches
they're going to be held it's going to
be like speech
in canton this fall i really you know i
think they've got to try you know i
totally get it i mean i do understand
you get you get one moment and you got
so many people you want to thank and
that's your time and i and i totally get
it so
but with that being said somehow we've
got to be able to get that
you know into a respectable amount of
time because
if you if you're the if you're the last
guy that goes
oh i was there one when kirk i was there
with kurt warner you know your
co-worker i was there when kurt warner
went in and and i don't think he even
took the stage till like 11 30 at night
and uh and it's not it's just not right
to the guys who go
towards the back end that uh you know
it's a it's a long long night so i gotta
figure that out maybe they started
earlier i
i don't know but i know that it's been
done for television for prime time and
all that's great but somehow when when
there's parties
and people want to go celebrate after
their you know
uh inductee gets in and and those aren't
start until
one in the morning i mean something
something's gotta give so i'm hopeful
that they figure that part of it out
but uh it is a special night for
everybody and and and i don't begrudge
anyone who goes long but
uh there are a lot of ramifications of
that no doubt and i i agree with you
what david baker the the president of
the hall of fame is doing
by the way the largest man to sneak up
on anybody
of all time you know what i'm saying
the biggest man i saw him next to john
madden one year
and then jonathan ogden and and jonathan
ogden is
is massive yes and both john madden john
madden's big too
john madden and jonathan ogden they they
looked like eight-year-olds next to
next to david baker the biggest human
being i've ever seen i know and he's
sneaking up on everybody no one sees him
coming he's sneaking up on everybody
yeah nobody sees him coming that's
amazing and not even peyton not even
peyton manning he said you got him
they got him hey troy uh thanks for the
call i truly appreciate it every time
you call
and uh and let's let's uh stay in touch
great season and i appreciate the
thoughts on super bowl 55.
you bet thank you red right back at you
that's troy aikman everyone
uh here on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here